[Music]  high school is a very interesting place  for him because it's kind of a place  where he gets to reimagine himself and  make himself the cool kid he's  functioning off of am i cool am I gonna  have the right shoes for the basketball  game am I gonna be able to go to these  parties he makes the wrong friends and  he doesn't know how to make the right  choices Hannah right great Justin you  don't like confidence do ya you don't  have geometry with mr. Bates victory  uses three thirds no yes I mean maybe I  like it  so could I like maybe get you your  number or something I'll just take your  phone huh one you give me your phone - I  put my number right  [Music]  [Applause]